welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for DC's The Flash coming this
June an adaptation of the flashpoint
crossover event bringing back both the
Michael Keaton Batman and the Ben
Affleck Batman as well as Michael
Shannon Zod from Man of Steel who knows
who else I now get why they didn't can
this movie despite Ezra Miller's
controversies because everything about
this from the competent tone to the
vibrant visuals from director Andy
machete to how good Keaton still looks
in that suit it's all in the lips baby
all of it has made this my most
anticipated superhero film of the summer
it's just what the DCU needs to turn the
page and we gotta break down this
trailer brain by frame because despite
it seeming to show a lot of the film it
definitely does I think the biggest
conflict in this movie is something that
this trailer doesn't really get into so
let's break it down also this Friday
February 17th will be the launch day of
our new channel the Deep dive in which I
will be doing more focused investigatory
analyzes of other movies that you love
you can best support our growing Network
by checking out our merch store
nerdriot.shop and you get stuff like
this from our deep dive collection Let's
see we also got mugs that are awesome
with our logo our deep diver vasmonaut
is also on a water bottle yeah all kinds
of great stuff so check it out support
us thanks all right let's get started
tell me something
you can go anywhere
another timeline
Another Universe
so Barry Allen tears and eyes appears in
front of his house as we hear the voice
of Michael Keaton Batman asking why he's
come back to this timeline of all
timelines and the next clip we'll hear
Barry say because this is the one
timeline where his mom lives so this
film based on the 2011 Flashpoint comic
event is altering the storyline rather
than translating it a to a the comic
event begins with Barry actually finding
himself de-powered in a universe without
the Justice League but with his memory
he's still intact in this universe
Batman is now an Uber violent Thomas
Wayne the amazonians and atlanteans are
at a war that is causing massive
flooding around Europe so Barry realizes
this timeline has been altered at some
point and he believes it is a doing of
reverse flash eobard Thon later realized
it was actually Barry's own doing in his
attempt to go back in time to prevent
his mother from being killed by reverse
flash there's a lot of other really cool
things that happen in the comics I
highly recommend you read this event but
this movie seems to be starting with the
choice to go back in time to save Nora
Allen Building on Barry's discovery of
his ability to reverse time in the
events of Zack Snyder's Justice League
league and in this movie rather than
speed forcing into a timeline and
assuming its own body at that point in
history Barry's Speed Force enabled time
travel has brought him to a side
Universe where he can encounter his
separate self in that timeline where
Nora Allen is still alive and that Barry
is de-powered because if he didn't lose
mom he doesn't become a superhero while
the Amazonian Atlantean War backdrop
doesn't really seem to be part of this
this is a universe without metahuman
protectors and so Zod went unstopped in
the Man of Steel events and rather than
this being a universe where Bruce's
father Thomas Wayne became Batman
instead of him it is one where Bruce is
played by Michael Keaton from the Tim
Burton era now that means we might not
get that emotional ending of the
flashpoint comics with Thomas's letter
to Bruce but I do think we'll get
another kind of cathartic Batman Legacy
send-off there is a quick shot of the
flashpoint Berry a Top Lane Banner looks
like that's a Gotham Skyline in the
background wait a minute it's so bright
that could be right got them supposed to
be gloomy gloomy so yeah this side
universe is just too happy too bright
and I hate it meanwhile back in Maine
Barry's original Universe there's a
quick shot of that universe is Batman
riding them motorcycle blue Cape stubby
your ears on the cowl yeah this is Ben
Affleck Batman I expect this story to
use Barry Allen as really a facilitator
to bridge the gaps among the different
eras of DC fans it's not just a flash
story it's gonna be a true DC crossover
event and it's gonna be awesome next
clip so why do you want to stay and
fight to save this one
so where my mom lives okay we see a hand
flipping a heavy switch which seems to
trigger the editing of the trailer
itself I think one of the reasons this
trailer is such a banger is they really
did a good job constructing this three
minute trailer into something that
really produces its own hype we flash
through a quick shot of feet levitating
off that same ledge on Wayne Manor I
think this is Sasha Kaye as Kara zorel
Supergirl this is kalel's cousin and
this may be the first moment she flies
in her official Supergirl suit now I
love the color shifting in this trailer
from the warm Golden Tones of youngberry
dancing with Nora in the kitchen to the
colder blue tones from the moment of
Nora's death Barry's father Henry is now
played by Ron Livingston recast from
Billy crudup in Justice League Barry's
shirt in the main timeline is also
shifted from yellow to Blue matching the
blue wall paint I think this color
Paladin will be helpful for us as the
film intercuts across timelines next
clip time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other like
magnets
I love the shot of young Barry running
out of the house on the morning of
Nora's death and the sky Zips from day
to night as adult Berry returns to this
memory and then we see an extreme
close-up of Bruce's hand with bruises
all over the fingers I mean this guy is
still cracking some skulls he touches
this old photo showing young Bruce with
his parents Thomas and Martha in the TV
version of this trailer we can actually
see Michael Keaton Bruce our man has
some Shaggy gray hair he's a true
shut-in he has to stuff it all into that
cow this bookcase wall is his hidden
entrance of the Batcave meaning our
man's gotta remember Martha to get in
Moving On
[Music]
my face so my face if you were to go
into the past you have no idea what the
consequences can be Bruce I could fix
things you could also destroy everything
okay so here main Berry runs into
alternate timeline Berry Maine Berry
wears his flash ring that contains his
suit alternate Berry doesn't have speed
powers and to him even the idea of
speedsters that metahumans is insane let
alone a multiversal variant of himself I
love though how main Berry eyes him
apprehensively as if trying to figure
out if this could be an imposter who
might have been the True Berry who is
behind Nora's death in another timeline
which might be teased by alternate
Barry's yellow headphones yellow clothes
yellow being the color of reverse flash
now I do not believe Zod is the primary
villain of this movie but I'm also not
sure if reverse flash is going to be the
direction they go but the trailer later
does hint at who the villain might be we
see a slow-motion shot showing the speed
force blasting through main berries back
and chest and then plunging into
ultimate Barry's body I assume this is
part of the sequence where they give
ultimate Barry's Speed Force powers in
this instance using main Berry as a
conduit I love this close-up of Barry's
ring as it spins the bolt logo is
splitting and then there's a glimpse of
his red bodysuit underneath assuming
this is how his suit is contained within
the ring I just love the Practical
smoothness of the parts it doesn't look
like a bfx nanotech spilling over the
body but rather a Rubik's Cube puzzle
with interlocking pieces Ben Affleck
Bruce Wayne Warrens Barry about
attempting time travel and I'm so glad
they got Affleck for this because this
all star Catholic and Ezra Miller's wild
moment in 2016's Batman v Superman so
from that moment Bruce must know that
Barry isn't going to listen to him it's
going to attempt time travel in the
future so structurally for this movie
starting with Affleck will give General
viewers a barometer of what era or what
Universe we start in so that they'll
better understand what Universe Berry
goes to in the second act with a
different Batman and possibly what
resolved Universe this movie ends in
maybe with a third new DCU Batman
introduced or at least hinted at if they
haven't cast him yet on to the next part
just kept me happening
completely broke the universe
besides we've been waiting for you I
created a world with no meta-humans
and now there's no one to defend us so
Barry sees on TV screens a similar
broadcast to the one Zod made in 2013's
Man of Steel to call out the other
Kryptonian hiding on Earth though I
don't remember his face being this clear
in those and then we see his world
engine pummily Metropolis as it did in
that film so it seems like Nora's death
was around the same time as zod's attack
in Man of Steel and that battle will be
the apocalyptic backdrop of all these
events except now there are no
metahumans to stop him or at least they
need a metahuman to step up and remember
after we Revisited the Battle of
metropolis from Bruce's perspective at
the opening of Batman v Superman I love
that we revisit it now from the
perspective of Barry or maybe from both
berries before we got that epic crane
shot of Bruce stirring up in anger while
he hugged that kid now it's this shot of
alternate Berry looking up but you can
see his hand trembling in fear Barry
finds his scraps of this Kryptonian suit
with the house of el sigil but in this
universe probably didn't ever belong to
Cal L but rather to Cara's cousin in the
comics it's a skinny pale version of
Kalel that they find in the government
captivity Clark having been there since
a young age with minimal human contact
and now it seems that they have swapped
that version of Clark with Supergirl for
this movie and I think it's interesting
because back in Zack Snyder's Man of
Steel Zack Snyder intentionally put an
extra open Kryptonian cryo chamber on
the Kryptonian ship that he heavily
implied contained Cara zorel and then we
see the exact moment for Man of Steel
where zod's ship first encountered the
US military in the desert and whereas in
that film Khalil was there to go with
them so there wasn't a conflict at least
not initially now Zod completely torches
the soldiers then moving on to my
favorite moment of this trailer want
some help
oh
you're
you are yeah
I'm Batman
oh yeah I like to have energy what I
don't like is feeling like the only way
to do that is chugging a giant energy
drink it's a lot easier to just pop out
one shot energy chew okay so just gonna
try one of these shoes here just gonna
do one of these because that's all you
need
so one shot Energy Chews are a healthy
and convenient energy boosting
supplement candy for gamers athletes
YouTube hosts everybody really each
energy chew has 75 milligrams of pure
caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional New Tropics to give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew and I'm and I'm
speaking from experience here and if
what you need isn't energy so much as an
added bit of focus well one shot also
makes some focused shoes looks like a
familiar kind of chew candy pop it in
nice and Lemony and great Focus chews
really help with concentration and give
you a natural boost of energy with B C D
and E vitamins plus zinc to help with
immune system support and the amino acid
tyrosine both Energy Chews and focus
shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals get
started with one shot energy today by
going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 30 off your order so the
berries find themselves in the Batcave
specifically with a sloped Art Deco
walls in rail failed walkways as the Tim
Burton era production design that's
clearly the Burton era of Batmobile
under the cover and the TV version of
the trailer one of the berries totally
uncovers it there's a bat wing hanging
from above though I don't remember the
Burton Batcave having a waterfall like
the Christopher Nolan Batcave definitely
had a waterfall I may just be
misremembering the Burton Batman films
now the scoring is a music box rendition
of Danny elfman's classic theme giving
this whole Batcave an antique Vibe and I
love the difference between the berries
and the reactions our main berries
Squints up trying to decode this Batman
variant whereas alternate Berry is
wide-eyed having never seen any Batman
up close before even though this is his
universe is Batman Andy Machinery uses a
similar camera movement as the dramatic
Glides that Tim Burton would use but I
love how the drama is undercut by not
all of the bulbs being lit above
Batman's head most are out actually
again we're looking at kind of an
antique store Batman it's kind of like
the opening to The Phantom of the Opera
with the monkey music box playing
masquerade leading to the sweeping 80s
Gothic score and you just gotta love The
Meta callback to the iconic 1989 moment
what are you
I'm Batman
hey that crook by the way Christopher
Fairbank who played Olaf in Star Wars
and or several other roles over the
years I love to see both this guy and
Michael Keaton having huge careers both
of them having shared that moment in
1989. on to the next clip
[Music]
okay here Danny Elfman score doesn't
even try to hide itself Batman does a 10
out of 10 dive to take out these
soldiers it looks like there's a lab at
the base of a silo looks like the same
location where Barry finds a Kryptonian
House of L suit and that lab actually
kind of looks like where he transfers
his power to all Berry I'm assuming this
is a place where they rescued Cara the
trailer editing matches this move with
the two berries back in the Batcave I
always love in moments when movies
double an actor and they play around
with the blocking like this like clearly
Ezra was shot on two different planes
falling behind the berry in the
foreground just sells that illusion
actually at one point the studio wanted
Robert zemeckis to direct this movie and
as a director who perfected this kind of
VFX and blocking and Back to the Future
Part Two and some really uncanny
seamless VFX movies like Forrest Gump he
really could have made an interesting
choice to do this but I gotta say anyway
is totally crushing the visuals here
okay back to the back like motorcycle
chase armed men in an armored Humvee
flip a police car notice many of the
buildings around them are covered in
construction scaffolding we could be a
metropolis here still rebuilding after
Pat's conflicts a quick shot shows Cara
flying upward cradling one of the
berries in her arms maybe seeking to
power him up with a bolt of lightning
moving on if I can't undo what I did
can't get back
there might not be a future
okay Barry watches the ground cave in
around the Gotham City Hospital you can
see it on the ambulance there but also
there's a sign in the upper left reading
Martha Wayne Institute so probably Bruce
philanthropically found in the wing in
the hospital for his mama so what's
causing the ground to crumble here I'm
assuming the world engine completing its
Terror formation affecting Gotham all
the way across the bay from Metropolis
we see Barry speeding up the side of a
crumbling building actually maybe we
will see a battle Metropolis where
someone was just focused on evacuating
as many civilians as possible we get a
quick moment of Barry with his love Iris
West but it looks like he is speeding
through this and only gets to spend
really a millisecond with her we see the
two berries both suited up dueling
colored speed forces getting to a halt
just touching boots now the berry on the
left is alt Berry wearing pieces of an
old bat suit that they modified you can
actually see the spray painted yellow
bolts on the Batman Boot and a knee pad
and then the 2021 teaser he's clearly
just wearing a rubber batsuit chest
piece that they spray painted over so
confirmed alt Berry will get powers too
so it looks like here they're Sweeping
in to stop sod's forces from torching
any more of the military in the desert
there's a quick shot in the bedroom a
few other Warner Brothers Easter eggs in
the posters Pacific Rim and I am Legend
now the 2007 movie I Am Legend actually
had an Easter egg of a Times Square
billboard for a Batman v Superman movie
years before that movie was announced by
Warner Bros we get this quick shot of a
batarang attached to a cable attracting
a lightning bolt like Ben Franklin's
kite with a key it looks like this is
what's going to initially charge the
bolt that goes from one Berry to the
other again Robert zabek is Back to the
Future it's all over the place here and
we get as gnarly close-up of these bolts
zapping through Barry's cheeks and his
face one popping off his tooth yikes
from behind we see Cara punching zot in
the face his face shield folding and
collapsing from the impact in the desert
battle main Berry spins and creates a
cyclone look out pocket tornadoes hate
that guy we get this quick shot of Cara
with her heat vision her house of el
sigil and suit back intact and then we
get our best look at bat Flex gray and
blue suit yellow utility belt mesh armor
plating this looks so sick they actually
pulled off a blue and gray suit Batman
in live action it looks like right
before the shot he had to bail from his
motorcycle and he's now skidding using
that grappling gun hook the car and ski
behind it before we move on there's a
very quick shot of alternate Berry
kicking someone else trapped in a fiery
Cyclone this might be the one that main
Berry produced now we know the kicker is
also buried because look at that helmet
that is a Batman cowl with the ears
shaped off but in that Cyclone that is a
thinner figure I wonder if that could be
a third flash maybe that dark Kryptonian
flash that's been rumored for this movie
that could be the true actual villain of
this movie's third act on to the next
clip
we try not to die
[Music]
foreign
are breaking car out of her facility
like the moment the flashpoint comics
when Barry and Thomas freed Clark from
his containment based on Kara's potato
sack clothes it looks like a facility in
Russia I love the framing of all this it
looks like it was all in one shot that
they broke up a bit for the trailer
pacing but you have to imagine Cara was
actually framed perfectly behind
Batman's raised hand for this entire
shot and is only revealed when he closes
his fist not a trailer unfortunately
cuts through all of it I get it for the
pacing but I just would have loved to
have seen this shot unbroken in the
trailer we'll have to wait for the movie
I guess but Cara moves with the speed
and the momentum that we are used to
seeing kryptonians move with in a Snyder
era of these films I love how they match
all that blocking and they take her back
to Wayne Manor we're behind her on the
table you can see the red and blue of
her Kryptonian suit waiting to be
tailored into her new suit which we see
her flying in in the final shot of the
trailer now I want to end this breakdown
with a few extra shots that we're only
seeing in the TV version of this trailer
so in this shot Barry prepares to speed
off his eye coverings extend down over
his eyes and if you look closely you can
see a digital interface in those
eyepieces a shot of Kara floated in
front of Zod and the desert paddle just
gorgeous shot composition with the dark
plumes of smoke behind her there's a
quick shot of Affleck Batman firing up
his motorcycle and we can see he is in
the back of his Airship meaning that he
drops down into the Chase from the air
you can actually see him landing on the
street a few seconds later in this and
then the Keaton bat cave has at least
seven different bat suits some of the
chess logos have been damaged one of the
cows has goggles on it this is likely
the suits that they use to get the parts
to make alternate Barry's new suit now
if you brighten this image you can
really see the differences between the
suits on the left that suit has gun
holsters maybe a year one Batman when he
was still using Firearms then to the
right of that a blue cowl and I just
love hokey in Batman and bat flick think
alike at different points of their lives
and then to the right of that the 1989
bat suit that's one with an emblem
that's damaged and then front and center
obviously the one he wears in this movie
and then behind that to the right the
1992 Batman return suit and then to the
right of that a scuba bat suit and then
the one with the goggles seems to be a
desert bat suit again Keaton and bat
like parallel thought as we know in the
Batman vs Superman nightmare sequence
bat like totally had a desert suit now
again we may not get the the flashpoint
Thomas to Bruce letter but I do think
the resolution to this movie will be the
formation of a new DCU and with that
clarified Universe the hint of a new
Batman to set up the Brave and the Bold
and James Gunn's upcoming slate I mean
think about it they have two Batmans
wouldn't it make more sense to have at
least the promise of a third again
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive launching this Friday with five
premium videos that you are gonna love
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign